it's amazing how artificial intelligence
seems to be taking over the world we
live in everything including our content
images seems to be influenced by AI I
believe it's not too far before AI takes
over the entire music industry and also
the way artists produce music hi I am
Diego sobayo and I live in the beautiful
city of Paramaribo on the banks of the
Suriname River I'm an aspiring Tech
entrepreneur and a co-founder of Mind
teams my keys is an online music
production company that produces and
sells Beats online throughout the world
I've been doing this for the past seven
or eight years as an entrepreneur I am
passionate about bringing Innovative AI
slash ml solutions to the market and
contributing to society in meaningful
ways I have always wanted to have a dual
career option besides music
for instance for the past few years I've
been mastering react native JavaScript
anti-script while also pursuing my
passion for artificial intelligence and
machine learning as an AI slash Emma
practitioner I have infested countless
hours into studying the latest trends
and Technologies in this field working
on personal projects and collaborating
with other developers to solve complex
problems
now it was time to get some formal
training it was during the pandemic that
I spent countless hours teaching myself
front-end development by October 2022 I
had a job at an American startup I used
that income to pay for the Caltech AI
Admiral bootcamp to follow my childhood
dream of building an AI tool ever since
I saw the movie Terminator 2.
my experience with simpler was very good
I think the course material is very
thoughtfully designed the way of
explaining was simple and easy to
understand the teachers were good
support was really helpful I would
definitely recommend this course to
others who want to start something of
their own in the AI domain I myself want
to start an AI startup and work on
problems that help Advance human
civilization I'm thinking about using AI
with computational neuroscience and
computational biology
after I'm Dominus this bootcamp I am
doing those two courses I am confident
that my diverse skills and
entrepreneurial spirit will enable me to
create innovative solutions that can
positively impact the world in my free
time I love reading books I love
producing new music content I guess
music username my DNA it will always be
I also enjoy researching the science and
engineering domain
as Nelson Mandela said education is the
most powerful weapon which you can use
to change the world
so what are you waiting for
go and change the world
foreign